let's jump right in most of you have
probably seen this so i'll just give you
some quick context
the atlantic trump americans who died in
war
are losers and suckers the president has
repeatedly disparaged the intelligence
of service members
and asked that wounded veterans be kept
out of military parades
multiple sources tell the atlantic now
for me i just call complete bs because
it's too cartoonishly evil like
the writers whatever the smear is and
then do a good job of making something
plausible
there's no possibility in my mind that a
president
wouldn't or trump specifically wouldn't
want disabled veterans front and center
because they're the best example of look
they lost this how much they sacrificed
take a picture with me
i'm the commander-in-chief this is an
opportunity for them to look great with
with the the populace so
that part i think is just absolutely
ridiculous not only that but didn't at
the rnc
they had a bunch of wounded vets stan at
the state of the union he had that north
korean refugee who had his leg run over
by a railroad and he stood up and held
his
uh crutch wow that was a very powerful
image and trump pointed him and
applauded this is cartoonishly evil
well as someone who's an actual comic
book super villain oh you know
there's been a comic written about me
this is something that i kind of aspire
to in a sense
but the the atlantic has been a very
malignant um
organization an outlet for over a
century at this point
so oh yeah so a lot of people don't
realize the history of the atlantic and
and
should i get into it now because let's
do let's do one more paragraph yeah yeah
please so people
yeah yeah so they go on to say that
trump uh in the first paragraph they say
trump canceled a visit to the ainmar
american cemetery in paris
he blamed rain for the last minute
decision saying the helicopter couldn't
fly
they go on to say neither claim was true
now i got to point out
jason leopold from buzzfeed has the foia
request from the navy they've got
numerous communications saying
the ceiling's too low visibility's too
low we're not going to be able to do
this and john bolton and his memoir also
independently describe this event and
john bolton his memoir was out to
at the very least not be flattering to
trump and he describes in
the the circumstance of this event
exactly as president trump later claimed
the
circumstances were so you have
independent uh like six months ago three
months ago corroboration
of trump's version of the events when i
would think i'm sorry interrupt you but
you would think they would mention
boltons
unless unless the intention was to be so
cartoonishly bad right
every conservative would be like it's so
obviously fake that
it's it's you know they're dangling keys
in front of a baby
and the conservatives ran right to it
and the narrative of the violent riots
and all the chaos in the streets and the
antifa killer is gone
yeah there's there's enormous wing of
conservatism which i have very mixed
feelings about
whose entire modus operandi is freaking
out over whatever it is the le the
liberals
are doing today and it does an enormous
disservice because
you know like you're saying it's a very
easy bait and switch like which of these
two things are in the grand scheme of
things a bigger issue
that people are getting killed by the
police rightly or wrongly
that chaos is descending rightly or
wrongly or
the president two years ago said a nasty
comment said naughty words
in the context of this presidency where
i mean the number of nasty comments that
he said has been
innumerable and will be in history books
one day hopefully and this is probably
like these are maybe actually not even
the worst things he's ever said of
course
i mean we were this is what they did
very cleverly in this is that everyone
very vividly remembers in 2015
when he was referring to john mccain i
was on on gutfelt show that day
referring to john mccain's military
service things like i like the ones who
didn't get captured right and
everyone thought okay this is the end of
the trump train because
you can't attack the military within a
republican context
and it turns out the republicans hated
john mccain more than they hate
making fun talking shake of military
service and it cost him
absolutely nothing other than perhaps an
invite to john mccain's funeral right
right but because of that it planted the
seed in a lot of people's minds
that trump would call a service member a
loser right
because it's plausible right i mean i
i don't i would disagree a little bit i
would say
some people have heard the story where
he called john mccain a loser and sent
out people who weren't captured
if they're not paying attention they
hear this and a lot of them are probably
like i can't believe you would say wow
like i can't believe it in the sense
that they believe it you know what i
mean like for me i look at this and i'm
like oh come on man
everything trump has been campaigning
since he got elected he got elected in
2016 and then he kept having rallies
non-stop right
he's been in full campaign mode and like
you mentioned he's had wounded vets at
his rallies of course
this is cartoonishly it's easy it's it's
ridiculous yeah but there's one more
thing i want to point out and then we
and then we could hear about what's
what's up with this and what
you know the atlantic they mentioned
that trump said he didn't understand why
the united states would intervene on the
side of the allies
and that you know he asked who were the
good guys
you know i find wrong with that is who
are the good guys um
us no no but see this is why i think
that's something he could have said
if he meant who were the good guys
germany or england or italy or germany
it was not a war of good versus evil it
was a war of like kings
versus shahs and versus
kaisers it's like why are we involved
here and it's a question that has never
been answered to our satisfaction to
this day
so yeah that's a very fair question yeah
this isn't a clear-cut good guys versus
bad guys this is
why are we there to begin with i think
because of the atlantic
because of the atlantic because of the
atlantic yes really so this this whole
story goes full circle
yes that's the so let's go okay bring on
the history there's someone named
randolph bourne and randolph-born
is a very interesting largely forgotten
historical figure he was the first
person who is journalist who was
handicapped who talked about being
handicapped
this is something where handicapped
people were invisible before
and he brought that to public attention
he died in
the spanish flu epidemic of i think it
was 1918 or 1920.
because of his disabilities he was the
dwarf and kind of misshapen his lung
capacity wasn't what it could have been
and he invented the term war is the
health of the state
and what was happening during the great
war remember woodrow wilson campaigned
on he kept us out of war
the idea that we'd be involved in a war
in europe completely violated the monroe
doctrine
this has been something that had been
the united states policy for 140 years
george washington in his farewell
address which was written by al
goldstrand by alexander hamilton said
avoid foreign entanglements
so we're gonna go to save like serbia
against italy against the
austro-hungarian empire it made
absolutely no sense
on american principles how do you get
americans to change
their minds well we all talk about in
school about yellow journalism and
william round of hearts the
spanish-american war remember the main
what they forget about is they act like
somehow that changed like there's yellow
journalism and then we don't talk about
it and now everyone's objective
it's been the same yellow journalism for
a
a hundred years and more the bloodlust
of the establishment in which i include
the corporate press cannot be overstated
and what happened with the great war is
for the first time
all the lefties became we need to get
involved we need to be the policemen in
the world
um william jennings bryan who had been
three times previously the democratic
nominee
who was a big left-wing populist he's
the one who brought like strong religion
to politics
he was woodrow wilson secretary of state
he was a pacifist he resigned over this
issue
so you can't the thing is you cannot to
this day
as president get people into war unless
the press
prepares them for it even if you have a
draft so what happened is all these
lefties
all of a sudden had huge ideas about
wait a minute
if we get into world war one that will
give us an excuse to micromanage the
economy
from a to z it had been bubbling under
since the early 1900s
and now we have an excuse we can imagine
what it would look like
if america was like a factory centrally
managed
from dc randolph-born was the only one
who said uh john dewey all walter
littman they're all there
john dewey uh uh randolph barnes the
owner said this is crazy
this is not what progressivism is about
we're not about
going overseas to fight on behalf of
kings what are you talking about
and they started saying well he's a
[ __ ] you shouldn't listen to anything
he has to say he he's crippling bodies
crippled in mind it was extremely
offensive
same thing happened later with helen
keller helen keller was a radical
communist
and they said oh well now you of course
she's she has no stock but she's
mentally disabled and she's like
i'm not mentally disabled i'm deaf dumb
and blind but my mind is fine like
yeah okay there go in the corner so this
is a pattern
with people on the left you're either
with us or you're just someone who could
be tossed in the garbage
um and the atlantic was one of the big
oh and he became completely blacklisted
so of course once he starts speaking out
about getting us into world war one
which makes no sense which really
destroyed so much
lives for what purpose uh he was
blacklisted john dewey wouldn't work
with him john dude was like the big
leftist intellectual at the time and
they all signed on and sold their souls
and that was the big this is why woodrow
wilson i think is universally
among the correct people regardless the
worst present history became among the
correct people yeah
became the uh this is when america
became globalist
and he was the first amer second
american president to leave
america as president teddy roosevelt
visited the panama canal
he went to europe the idea of a
president leaving america
wasn't you would never think of it
before because the whole point of a
president is to stay in your country
now every president is getting on jet
every other weekend this was not the
role the president he's supposed to be
here
and hold the fort and i use the term
fort advisedly so the atlantic
has a lot of explaining to do which they
never have had to do
for all their pro-war propaganda and
here's where it gets even more evil
deborah leipzdot did an amazing book
called beyond belief
and the premise of this book was about
what the press was covering as hitler
rose to power in germany
now you didn't have the internet you
didn't have cell phones you didn't have
youtube anything like that
so they're getting all these reports and
these reports of what hitler and the
nazis were doing
you you only have cameras even that much
to that extent seemed crazy and
implausible oh maybe people
and they pointed to all the war
propaganda from world war one
when they talked about how evil the
kaiser was this was a world where the
kaiser is the most evil human being on
earth
and that was later proven to be false so
they're like listen we heard this 20
years ago
you guys lied about the hun and how the
huns killing people and raping
everyone oh and now hitler's here now
he's doing these things yeah you know
what
you're
talking about and this is a major
impediment in stopping hitler's rise to
power
and you can lay the blame at agencies
like the atlantic
the new republic and all these other uh
depraved and malfeasant outlets this is
actually a challenge right now with
china
yes so with what they're doing with the
uyghur muslims and all that yes
i've actually had people ask me yeah but
certainly you don't think
war is you know is the answer and things
like that well not necessarily
but we do have to recognize the things
that they're doing the videos we've seen
the reports that are coming out of china
are
horrifying but what do we do
and i think a lot of people are now in
this kind of purgatory where
yeah we've been lied to too much yes the
media's gung-ho
go war i think what trump's trump's the
last the
the first president a long time no new
wars yes and so that's one of the things
that made me kind of turn
on okay when he tried to pull the troops
out of afghanistan and and bring
our troops back and i've heard of
opinions from a lot of people but
there there is a real challenge in when
is war appropriate
i would personally say yeah world war ii
was
something we should hitler should have
been stopped a long time ago should have
never gotten to that point
i didn't know that about how the the
fake news essentially
impeded you know this book beyond belief
is just absolutely
mind-boggling it's just amazing because
she very much defends the press in the
sense of you can understand
why they were so skeptical because they
heard it all 20 years ago
and this is germany this is a civilized
country they're going to be acting like
they're going to be beating up old
people in the street okay come on
let's let's have some perspective and it
was true
the corporate press yes the corporate
press is the enemy of the people and
that is the moderate
that is the moderate position yes
i mean they've been at it for over a
hundred years and i wrote this piece for
the observer a couple years ago about
obama in the tan suit and i said it's
very useful
to have a president like trump who's
regarded as a buffoon
because if you have a president who's
widely respected you will smile and nod
when he sends your kids to war
to die overseas for sometimes no reason
there's an amazing traveling exhibit
which i saw at ut austin called the
great war
which is about world war one and i left
it crying because you have all these
letters from these kids
17 18. hey mom we're in brussels
everything's cool and the plaque is like
he died next week for what
for what the amount of car you know
plastic surgery was invented as a result
of world war one because of all that is
fake
because everyone came back disfigured
like chopped up because it's the first
time you had human bodies
meeting with the industrial revolution
that created these machines
it was just absolutely horrific what was
done to all these kids the amount of
bloodlust in that was the e-press field
and there's just one more thing there's
a very very beautiful
very very evil poem which they love in
canada called in flanders fields
and the point of this poem if you want
you could pull it up it's pretty short
is it's it's speaking from the voices of
the dead
and it's saying we're lying here where
the poppies grow
are you going to let us die in vain come
over and join us
so that idea is like you're not going to
let all these people who died die for no
reason
you have to die also because otherwise
our deaths were pointless it's it's so
sinister
when you sit down and think about it and
there was a principle at the time
that to be a real man you know you had
to join and fight for war
and this was a time when all the ivy
leagues like these men were the first
ones to sign up and now we look back at
it and it's just like this is kind of
crazy
how it was glorified that it's a great
idea
you know you to be a real man you got a
call to war even if after the fact
you're like what was this about
you know what who were the who were the
good guys
i i don't know if i would believe that
trump
as a president would be saying things
like i agree with you you're right
so the story to me comes off as absurd
but i do think it's fair to say
one thing that we're educated about
relentlessly
world war ii yes when it comes to world
war one
yeah it's i've gotten i actually
remember when i was in school
we read a little bit about of it but it
was pat read a little bit but it's
passed over almost immediately for world
war ii
and it's almost like world war one is
used in the context of what led to world
war ii right
like the the germans were upset about
the debt and they felt you know they
wanted retaliation and things like that
but we we're not taught the history of
all
there really is an over emphasis on
world war ii for sure yeah and i think
there's good reason for it
but that's an easy story to tell there
really is that is a good that is good
versus evil
right or good versus good and evil
versus evil because stalin's on our side
but we don't we don't they don't teach
us necessarily
we don't get it hammered into us by our
culture about how how bad
you know stalin was and we also don't
get hammered into like a lot of
the government and the press lied and
manipulated us
into a war which 100 years later we
can't explain
why we were in which led to the the
normalization the idea of
totalitarianism on american shores
and here's the other thing woodrow wils
there's a concept i call
evangelical progressivism i talk about
this in my book than you write
very heavily and the premise is there's
different kinds of leftism it's not a
monolith
and there's this evangelical strain it's
a fundamentalist faith
and woodrow wilson came out of that
school and which extends very much to
this day and the idea of
there was something called the social
gospel and the social gospel
is a very twisted idea and it says you
don't take the christian idea of saving
an individual soul
you can save an entire nation right a
nation has a spirit that has to be
redeemed
now if you are going to redeem the
spirit of an entire nation
that means everything in your life is on
the table the bedroom
the boardroom on the street everything
is a
a vehicle for sin and everything is
there for up to discussion
and he talked in literally
messianic terms about how it's america's
got his extremely religious man
america's role to save the world and
when you have that trickle down a
hundred years later
it's like whenever there's anything
going on it's our responsibility
even if we really can't do anything
about it and everyone listening to this
remembers not that long ago if we
weren't in syria
all the kurds would be killed it was
another holocaust and no one
who said that has had any accountability
for their lies
in trying to get americans to be
overseas
dying in a war where it's not very clear
who the good guys are again
but we've had we've had strong glimpses
like
i shouldn't even take a glimpse and
we've been smacked in the face with this
when the new york times lied about wmds
in iraq oh yes of course
and now there are kids who are you know
preparing uh i i don't know if
what do they say they're not i got
interrupted not just wmds that he's
about
to fire them it wasn't that he had them
it's that he's about to use them
iran is about to nuke israel now for 20
years any minute now
we laugh but you know this says
extremely
did you so so it you know going back a
little bit to the fact that the
atlantic's goal was to shift a cycle to
benefit trump
yeah one of the questions he got asked
joe biden was
you know some something like are you
concerned that peace agreements in the
middle east with israel will destabilize
palestinians to you know
efforts for a two-state solution or
something and i'm like are you literally
trying to undermine
peace agreements in the middle east they
are absolutely of course they are
they're warmongers yes they cannot their
bloodlust cannot be overstated and i
gotta cut joe biden some slack because
he did fight in world war one
so yeah you know it's a little different
for him he remembers it when it was just
palestine
yeah yeah i think
you mentioned syria yeah you know we
we're we're still in afghanistan yeah we
still have a small
it's not the biggest presence that you
know compared to where it was why are we
in germany
i mean did we ever leave we never left
yes
are we still occupying germany yes i was
so i was watching this movie the
resistance banker okay and
i mentioned several times now it's a
good movie it's about a this this dutch
guy
his name was van hall i forgot william
van hall i think i'm not sure
but uh he helped fund the resistance
against the nazis in the netherlands
it's an amazing story about how he did
this scheme to like
they they backed up money for people
once the government which was in exile
came back they'd pay back people this
money
and uh i totally forgot where i was
going with that because i started
thinking about this movie and being cool
and like fighting against the nazis oh
yeah
anyway so i'm watching this and i'm
reading wikipedia about world war ii and
stuff
and it's like what happened at the end
of world war ii the allies occupied
part of germany then the commune the the
you know the soviets occupied
east germany and then i was like oh okay
and then i read about like you know the
berlin wall fell and i'm like when did
we leave germany
yeah no we didn't there's a great book
called 1946
which is about what happens when world
war ii ends and europe is a complete
wasteland and how they rebuilt
and there's one story which no one talks
about because it's weird
it doesn't fit the good guy bad guy
thing which is the czechs in
czechoslovakia
they took all the germans or people
german descent even people who lived
there for 100 years
put a sign in their back that says
german and made them walk wait what
really yes they
walked into the get the f out of
czechoslovakia and they walked to the
border many died along the way it was a
trail of tears they were germans
yes all any germans in czechoslovakia
get the f out
wow yeah and a lot of them died and they
were like i've never been to germany i
don't care you can't you can stay where
you want you can't stay here
wow yeah but you know what you can't in
one sense
it's like in 40 years you guys have
decimated this continent
like we have had enough of you people
and you're blaming the jews for all this
too
you you people are just horrible but
that's
racist isn't it like it's german or race
i don't know ethnicist like those german
people didn't do anything they did not
no no they certainly did not they're
just like regular people
and many of them certainly left germany
because they're like i don't want to be
around this
wow man that's brutal yeah that's crazy
but
everyone will always tell you that
europe europeans are much more moral
than us and we should aspire to be like
europe
oh yes every five minutes you hear this
so so it seems like the goal
i wonder if if you know trump not
starting a new war is part of the reason
why they hate him
i think that he's it's not it's not only
that he's not starting a new war
we told you we told you you have to
start a new war we told you if you don't
do this it's genocide
and you're waving your hand no no no
that's not how this works
what works is we tell you where there's
a problem and you as president as
commander-in-chief
send the troops there and fix the
problem this has been the deal
for over a hundred years what are you
doing orange man bad
so so is you know that uh that story
about the chimps in the
in the in the study with the ladder and
the fruit or whatever no so it's like
they put five chimps in this room and
then they put like a step ladder or like
a tall ladder and they put fruit on top
and then anytime a chimp would climb
climb the the stepladder they'd spray
him with a hose okay all of the chimps
all the chips get sprayed
and so then eventually when a chimp
would try climbing the ladder the other
chimps would grab him and beat him up
like you're going to get us
don't do it then they took one chimp out
and put in a new chimp
that chimp that never got sprayed with
the hose before but when that chimp
climbs up the other chimps beat them up
one by one they swap out all the chimps
never using the hose
culture yeah and then the chimps just
kept beating anybody who went near the
ladder not knowing what the real ram
you know what was the was the punishment
i wonder
if if that's why there's this war
machine it's just the way it's always
been
the like the people who who started the
process of
of just non-stop international war and
conflict well they're dead
they're sure a long time sure and so now
their grandkids
are the ones being like but we have to
go to war but i don't think it's just a
question of principle for them i think
it's a question of status
it's a question of wealth it's a
question of power if i'm the guy who
decides who lives and dies and can
conquer the fates of entire countries
that feels pretty good to me and then
you have this
mor this you know [ __ ] in the white
house who does he think he is where like
this has been the process and now you're
coming in and turning over the apple
cart
that's not how the rules work buddy go
back to new york well so let's
let's let's expand this into uh uh you
know i mean these people make a lot of
money
oh definitely and i think there's also a
very sadistic
thrill in knowing that you're
responsible for sending so many people
to their deaths
but if the us wasn't doing it who would
be would there would be someone
in you know the soviets would they they
were doing this these expeditions in
other places china's doing it now i
don't think it's a given that there
would be this kind of
uh one world power uh that is
has its fingers in every pot i mean if
you look at let's suppose kuwait right
that was much more of a multinational
operation you had the us you had britain
but basically everyone was on the same
page on that it's not implausible that
you would have this kind of coalition
that would kind of make sure no the
borders are enforced because it's useful
for the powerful to maintain the status
quo
it's like gang warfare this is my tariff
this is your turf
we shake hands the problem is when you
have actors in bad faith like china like
what happened with hong kong
and that is something that all of us as
americans should be far more disturbed
about than kovid
because they're going to push the
envelope until they get pushed back and
why wouldn't they
well so if the u.s so so here's the
arguments that i've heard right
if we leave afghanistan there's two big
problems a humanitarian crisis sure this
is what sean parnell was saying and
i think it's true he says all these
people that helped us
or are sympathized they're going to be
dead just they're going to go and kill
all these people and we can't
what do we do we don't just leave these
people to die sure and i'm like that is
it that is
that that's a serious challenge although
i i think we've kind of created this
mess for ourselves we gotta find a way
out the other issue is
china moves in yeah you know now that
there's a power vacuum
they can come in they can take control
the territory and use it for strategic
purposes or
you know for resources and then china's
already
pushing into other parts of the world
south america africa there was
are you familiar with what they were
trying to do with the nicaraguan canal
no i know they're pulling out of africa
to some extent but please educate me so
this was several years ago that
i believe the project fell through but
we we you know we essentially control
the panama canal which is very very
powerful
they wanted to just rip through
nicaragua and that's that's
massive that's not panama yeah panama's
like by design they've
picked it for a reason because it's the
shortest one yeah but so they worked all
these deals and it would have apparently
destroyed like this massive freshwater
aquifer and decimated a lot of local
population
ultimately it fell through but they were
moving towards this the ultimate goal
being
they want to supplant us they want to to
they're pushing us out
and then the fear i have is yeah man i
hate these foreign
you know excursions or whatever you want
to call them the us likes to hop around
they you know the the syria thing
there's a there's a lot of uh
i i guess i could call it speculation
because i'm not a middle eastern policy
expert but like
the qatar turkey pipeline right you're
familiar with this yes they're trying to
build a natural gas pipeline up through
syria through turkey into europe
to essentially i i'm correct if i'm
wrong offset
the gazprom gas monopoly in europe so
this
leads to war all these conflicts so i'm
not a fan of of us being like we should
get cheaper gas in europe and russia's
you know strangling us on this so we
want syria to bend the need to us and
then syria says no and then
oh lucky for us there's an uprising and
the u.s is on the side of the people who
oppose this
but there is all that being said
do we sit what do we do if china is
gaining territory and moving around and
doing the things they're doing
they're quite quite literally running
concentration camps yeah i mean
listen i wrote the book on north korea
so i am not at all a fan of the chinese
government and
the north korean government this is
something that's you know my wheelhouse
and i've been you know warning about
this for many years and thankfully the
audiences have been extremely receptive
to hearing this story
uh honestly what i would say if this if
the corporate press wasn't as depraved
as it is it would be very easy or
moderately easy to get us to side with
russia against china
oh yeah it would there's been a very
long history
decades long of rivalry between russia
and china between mao and all the
russian leaders
it would be very if we were combined
against them it would be
pretty much unstoppable but because the
corporate press has made putin
for no reason that's ever been explained
to be the worst dictator on earth
this has now become radioactive and if
trump made moves
to strengthen his relationship with
russia which would benefit a lot of
people if russia and the u.s were teamed
up in the middle east
that would solve a lot of problems
because we could between us
could sit a lot of these countries down
the more moderate ones and be like look
we're locking you guys in a room figure
it out you know and
they bang on the door to let out but it
happened with uae that's gonna be the
first domino you invite them to the rec
center
yeah and then once they all come in they
realize both sides are there then you
lock the door
exactly yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you